All right, what we're going to talk about next is the idea that there're are some problems
such that if we could solve them fast, we could solve all problems in NP fast,
and we call those problems the NP hard problems.
I don't find that to be a particularly useful name, but it's the name that everybody uses
so I will use it as well.
How can we say that some problem X is at least this hard,
at least within polynomial factors, as some other problem Y.
To phrase it anyway--if X is at least as hard as Y, what can we do with an algorithm for X.
Well, we could use it to solve Y.
In fact, that's maybe what we mean by saying that X is at least as hard as Y
that we can use as solution to X to solve Y.
The basic picture that you can have in your head is something like this,
Imagine that we want to solve an instance of problem Y, we can imagine building a solution
algorithm, an algorithm for Y, that what happen inside is instance of problem Y gets transformed
in some way between instance of problem X or may be multiple instances of problem X.
Then we run an algorithm for solving problem X to get solutions to those and maybe that generates
more instances but after polynomial number of calls to this algorithm, what comes spitting out
is a solution to the original instance of problem Y.
We basically have solved problem Y by bringing to to bear our solution to problem X,
or to say it another way, problem Y has been reduced to problem X.